last day of a three which is exciting
and uh
just--there's thankful for those of us
who were very very tired I'll probably
everyone at this table I'm back with
Kali my name is Jess and we got Danny
here with us uh you're here to talk
about Far Cry 5 it's absolutely one of
the biggest games that we've had to talk
about this e3 I know we're both super
pumped for it I mean every time you
announce a new Far Cry setting a new Far
Cry game it's like well how was a really
good idea it looks really cool and I
don't think I've ever felt that way more
than this time round that's great to
hear we're hearing tons of great
feedback I think you know everybody was
saying where's the next one gonna be how
are we gonna make it fresh and different
and I think nobody was expecting Montana
absolutely not and I think you know
where we people typically think you know
we put you on a plane we take you for
6,000 miles away we drop in the middle
of a jungle somewhere and this time we
wanted to bring it to the States
I wanted to make it feel like it was
real and interesting it wanted to be
something that people would explore the
frontier of a far cry experience but
they could do it almost close to home I
think people are loving it they're
playing they're playing it here at e3
and obviously boomers the big standout
everybody knows the dog so it's super
cool to see I would really like to talk
about the dog for a second because when
I play the demo of course I picked
boomer yeah uh you can pet him if you
did not know that um what was the
thought process behind adding boomer was
just like people do love dogs you know
what it was we were we were actually in
Montana and we were hunting and it was
kind of the it was the end of the day
and was kind of cold and we were hungry
and everybody's like ok you know let's
get back in the truck and then all of a
sudden the guy that were with says hey
listen don't move like ok right and we
watch the dog he was like a dog that he
has with him is pretty cool but like the
interesting looking dog and he goes just
watch the dogs we walked up for what
felt like an eternity
and we're like ok what is this dog in to
do something in the last minute parks
and this burgos gone then then he goes
to shoot at and I was like always trust
your dog sauce and that feeling of you
know this companion that's gonna that
you know when boomer runs up to you and
he drops that gun off that he's just
taken off somebody and he looks at you
like I'm a good dog right and you're
like you're good boy boomer talk yeah
sir I mean I unfortunately haven't
gotten a chance to play the game yet but
I assume you can't lose your companions
completely I just want to know the dog
smoked it every day yeah absolutely in
the dog dies kill boomer we don't kill
me I saw every time a massive gang comes
out with a dog it's like
that's there's a whole website dedicated
that actually does the dog die does it
mom
yeah so I guess expanding off of boomer
I love him but we should talk about
other things you have this guns for hire
system and he's one of them um he talked
a little bit more about others three
available in the demo that's the I got
to see are there more do you gain them
throughout school there's stuff I'm
supposed to talk about stuff I'm not
okay that's course you know we built
this big you know guns for hire system
we have fangs for hire we have friends
for her with co-op as well and so we
just want to be able to make it that you
go out into the world and you see
somebody like boomer or somebody like
grace and that they all have their own
unique skills right now boomer is gonna
be somebody who's very much like almost
like a bio drone he can go out into the
world and and because the cult doesn't
recognize boomer and and isn't worried
about him all right you can go in and
tag people this grace grace is gonna be
somebody who's got your back yeah you
put her up too high she's basically got
the sniper rifle and she's gonna be
there to protect you in case this stuff
goes down yeah I really really liked
grace I didn't I pick boomer of course
but I do like sniping so I was like I'm
gonna be the one sniping Google who's
gonna be taking care of the guys on the
ground but um yeah it's an interesting
mechanic can you talk about co-op a
little bit more else yeah I think you
know a lot of people were asking us you
know because the DNA of the brand is
definitely coming from a single-player
experience yeah so we want to make sure
that we keep that sacred and that it's
that it's people who want to be able to
play it that way Ken same thing with
guns for hire same thing thanks for
higher that if you want to play with
them you can but you don't have to and
then when it comes to co-op on Far Cry 4
what we did is we had it so that you
could play it on the open world but a
lot of folks were saying well can we do
it in missions can we get it in quests
and for Far Cry 5 absolutely want to be
able to give you that that's so exciting
when did you decide like this is
something we're gonna do so I mean there
there are not loads of co-op campaigns
out there true you know what I think
it's just it's a natural evolution for
us yeah we're a big game or a big brand
and what we wanted to be able to do is
make sure that people can play it the
way they want to play it I think that
when you think about what makes Far Cry
great is that we've built this anecdote
Factory right and when we were first
figuring out kind of what we had at the
end of Far Cry 3 we looked at the game
and we said okay what's really cool
about this is that you can go out into
the world and you can find an outpost
and you have the ability to take that
outpost from 360-degrees right yeah then
you have the freedom and the opportunity
and the surprise of looking down maybe
there's a bear in a cage and you know
that once you kick that off it's going
to go
but you don't know how we thought we
would take that freedom opportunity
surprise and applied to the entire game
for far cry 5 so we drop you in the
middle of the world you can go in any
direction meet anybody you want you can
have a completely different experience
and somebody else is playing go down
south go north and we just it's all
about freedom
yeah and it's a that's a good
opportunity for co-op too because you
can attack something from multiple sides
you can say okay I'm gonna go over here
and do this you're gonna let that bear
out of the cage yeah there's a lot of
it's it's just cool to see that people
are playing it the way they want to play
it and the game is responsive even on
the floor we're watching people play it
they're playing it completely different
right
annalee we're watching and do stuff that
I didn't even know was possible it's
okay oh yeah that must be fascinating
like you have an example of that well
the thing is is that we were playing the
demo or like all right people were gonna
go and they're gonna attack falls in and
then you know we're watching people go
you know what I'm just gonna go meet
Nick I'm just gonna go meet another
character what happens when you walk up
to Nick and you have a conversation with
them and then you decide mid
conversations you just leave it right
what does he do how does it react and as
a normal human being he goes all right
you know I'll talk to you later and then
when you come back he goes here's where
I wa and so it was it feels very real
that's interesting I always feel bad for
like virtual characters so I'm like I
can't walk away you're talking to me and
yet live it so you get the opportunity
when a bunch of people are playing your
game on the show floor exactly or you
have different people maybe nick is in
the middle of the conversation with you
and something you know the cult drives
by he it doesn't feel real if he doesn't
react it doesn't feel real if he if he
doesn't stop and look around and is
careful and cautious and so we build the
system be able to do that so that they
feel real yeah yeah I mean you're taking
on so many things that farcry doesn't
seem to have really touched before I
mean you're in a very different setting
it's big it's quite familiar yes you're
in America but very different than what
you've done before you do a lot of
research into the themes you were
dealing with what was successful I think
that you know from the standpoint of
this this game we've been we've been
working on this game for about three
years two and a half years and I think
the key thing for us is to do our
homework so we actually went to Montana
we were actually there and the one thing
that we really wanted to be able to do
was what was it was it believable that
you could go to this and have this
situation happen where a cult could take
over a space and you would feel like you
were cut off yeah we were in Montana
we're there for about 24 hours over the
course of first 24 hours we're there for
14 days total but in that first 24 hours
are like okay how isolated do we feel
yeah so we're in these vans what kind of
driving along and then we go through
this mountain pass and our cellphone
signal drops me back in tank yeah yeah
doesn't come back really unless you go a
couple days without your phone and you
realize nobody has a clue where you are
oh my god I'm talk to y'all noisy and
cut off yeah right and so for us it was
a really interesting feeling to get that
feeling of being cut off and then make
it feel like what happened if something
went down here how would we get that
message out what happened if somebody
closed the roads or what happened to
somebody cut us off in the outside world
how believable would be and within 24
hours we knew it was completely
believable Wow
one of the things that really excites me
about far cry 5 is you're dealing with
things that are getting really close to
home kind of in the world right now and
it makes I mean far cry 5 has always had
threatening settings but for me it makes
me like like uncomfortable and
threatened in a way that I didn't really
expect to be I mean what is it like
writing about a dystopian setting that
is so close to home you know when I was
a kid so where the idea comes from is
like when I was a kid I was a child of
the 80s and so in I was about 10 years
old in 82 and what I remember is I
remember the pressure and sort of the
weight of the Soviet Union in America
locked in this cold war and I remember
this feeling as a kid that it just felt
like you know everything could go south
really quick and as a kid you don't know
how to handle that right and it created
this feeling of you know it's this
heaviness and so basically what happened
was is that you know in 89 when the wall
came down I think globally everybody
kind of went okay we're safe Wow but
then what I notice is that in the last
10 12 years that feeling starting to
come back
oh absolutely isn't starting to get this
feeling like and so what was interesting
about that is building a character who
had that feeling building a character
like you know because we know we have
the pedigree of making great characters
like Los second min but now apply that
feeling to the father
yeah apply that feeling to the father
and have him have a mandate of basically
trying to in his own way save as many
people as you can from this collapse
that he believes is coming and it
creates a really powerful character yeah
I mean there's that excellent quote I
want to say comes from just waiting but
I can't say if that's particularly true
about about villains and the best
villains are the ones who believe that
they're the good guys yeah do you think
that applies for sure am
this is what he believes he believes at
the end justify the means and the what
he's doing is when he takes you right
he's basically saying I I know you don't
want me to save you from what's
happening but and I know you don't
believe me and I know you don't trust me
but the truth is is that after the
calamity happens after this collapse
happens and when it's all over you will
say thank you yeah he believes that
which means that he's a really complex
character and we had a lot of great
stuff from him
yeah there's a lot of potential for
nuance there I do want to ask I don't
know if you can answer so forgive me but
uh about the player character you play
this a sheriff's deputy can you tell us
a little bit more about that you know
what we did and it's one of those things
it's kind of a pet peeve of mine
whenever I'm playing a game and I have a
moment where I'm like I freaked out or
whatever and I have a I basically say
something that it should be my voice or
what I want to hear or what you guys
want to hear when you play the game it
annoys me when you end up getting a
character that says something that you
don't think the chatty characters yeah
absolutely I also don't like the idea
that you go from zero to hero in ten
seconds yeah and so what was interesting
is to be able to make you this sheriff's
deputy and make it so that it was
believable that you had a little bit of
experience with a gun but you didn't
have you know you had a six-shooter or
something and that you basically were
heading out into the world and then that
this character was you so we built an
avatar system that basically you can
make it you so that it is your game and
it is it is your expression again mm-hmm
and then I mean going back to the
setting and how that interconnects I
mean is it is a game where you feel more
vulnerable as a result of that as a
result of who you are and where you are
it's a good question I think that people
will definitely feel like they're in the
space they'll feel like they're and
that's something that's the benefit of
making a first-person game is that
whenever you make an interesting
character a nuance character they can
get into your space right they can get
into your personal space and that makes
it really really interesting in terms of
the play that you can get and the
characters that you can get and the
moments that you can have with these
characters and even your guns for hire
right that's the other thing we want to
do is that yes we built a great
character with the father and yes he has
a family that's with him which makes our
cast larger this time but we also wanted
to make it that your guns for hire and
that your fangs for hire had personality
even down to boomer or even down like to
Nick and his story or grace or Casey are
these different characters you meet we
wanted to make sure that these people
felt real they weren't just characters
in the
waiting to give you missions right they
had a life they had a mandate and if you
didn't help them there we can help
themselves and you showed that off with
those character vignettes that came out
a little while ago ahead of you three we
got to see like Mary May yeah all that
stuff yeah are there lessons that you
reckon you've learned in the process of
making far cry for sort of long now that
you sure would have applied to this game
yeah I think there's there's two things
is that like whenever you finish a game
you always leave cool ideas on the
cutting room floor making right at this
game we wanted to take the right amount
of time to be able to get everything
that we wanted in and the second thing
is that when you're working with writers
and actors and whatnot it's really
important that the process allows them
to be able to it can't just be what's in
your head it has to be it's alchemy
right so whenever you get into a room
with an actor and you're making a great
character it's not something that you
have on a page it's something that you
find together and so we're learning a
lot of stuff about letting the actors
run certain things and and what feels
natural what feels right and we've got
some great actors I mean Greg bricks
amazing as the father a spooky as hell
it's fantastic to get these performances
and then the other thing too I would say
is it's different for us is because
we're building a world where you can go
in any direction and you can meet
anybody and have these action bubbles we
built a writers room
so we have it's not just one writer
writing a story it's a whole bunch of
different people who are owning a
character or owning a section and it
feels very organic and I think that you
end up getting that reflection in the
game right you get that individualism
from different people collaborating on
one thing right yeah um I do want to
hear a little bit more about the rest of
the cult so we've seen the the eldest
just the youngest face I'm very curious
about faith in particular because I feel
like but the father if he believes that
he's doing the righteous thing even
though he's you know to us he's not
faith seems a little more ambiguous to
me it makes me the most nervous I think
it's just the one who kind of a pieces
everyone right well I think that you
know we did a lot of research on cults
and without giving too much away from
the game because there's a bunch of
other stuff that we'll be talking about
soon um but what was really interesting
about cults is that typically you know I
think when you get an idea of what a
cult is people have this sort of flash
in their mind of what it what it is but
what's really interesting is just that
is the different personalities involved
right
and so from the father standpoint he
surrounds himself with a chorus of
people who have jobs they have roles to
play and so one of them is perhaps the
person who goes out and gets people and
brings them into the cult the other
person is the one who protects the cult
and then there's somebody who pacifies
everybody and keeps them quiet and keeps
them calm and that's definitely faith
and I think what's really interesting is
seeing how they each have a role
they each have a responsibility and they
also both are all of them sort of look
at the father and they have different
opinions about how the father operates
right it's not just that they're blindly
following him they have opinions about
whether or not what he's doing is right
whether or not he's doing it correctly
whether or not they even believe him and
it's really interesting to see that
they're human beings and that they're
going to they're going to go out and
they're going to take the mandate that
he's giving them and execute it in their
own way okay yeah it's like a lot of
times when people hear the word cult
they think if people have been
brainwashed area as opposed to people
who kind of have their own agency so
would you say like these people are
operating kind of on their own term I
think there's there's no question that
there's going to be blind following of
the father but that's also going to be
people who are who are doing it for
perhaps their own reasons right when I
think about even characters like Jacob
or or whatnot the older brother this is
somebody who just needs a mission this
is somebody who just who almost from a
personality standpoint it doesn't matter
what he's doing as long as he's doing
something man so you know you pointed
you basically he's a weapon and you
point them in a direction and you're
gonna churn through that it makes a
really interesting character oh how do
you feel I mean oh you must been asked
this a million times but how do you feel
about handling like subject matter like
that like I mean it's really not
something that's dealt with quite often
probably because I would assume a lot of
game developers are nervous about
handling it in a certain way I mean how
did your team approach that how do you
feel I think for me personally when I
look at you know television and film and
whatnot they've been doing this for
years 60 60 years of being able to sort
of explore topics and be able to to be
able to go and try different things I
think for us is that games have really
come of age yes and so there's we can
look at this in the exact same way as TV
or movies and we can explore similar
topics and we know that we can you know
we can trust that people understand that
we're in
and brand this is entertainment and that
that's also why we built hope County
it's not a place that you can fall right
yeah world is ours it's why we built our
own cult and we named it and we gave it
its its its mandate basically so that it
was ours but we understand that it's you
know it's something that I think that
since movie and television I've been
able to do it for so long I think we can
too yeah why not game exactly I was like
you put a lot of care into it we did
this is absolutely been a labor of love
for sure yeah um speaking of just
building Hope County how big is it
because I I mean it's kind of a small
town but I feel like there's a lot of
land right like how much can we expect
so I think you know without giving too
much away from the standpoint of the
actual size of the world what we did
when we built this thing is that we made
sure that it was when you think about
how big Far Cry 3 or 4 Cry 4 was people
can understand the trajectory were on
okay but we really wanted to do is make
it so that you could tackle it in any
direction you could go in any direction
so that's a big departure for us is that
typically what we've done in the past is
that you would go and you'd be walking
along and you'd meet this character
you'd meet it in this order and we'd all
have the same story
right but for us what it is is building
the world so that it's organic building
the world that you go out and that right
from the get-go once you have that first
moment with the father and you find
yourself alone in the world that you can
go in any direction you can meet any
character and you can have an experience
that you author and it will be different
from if you guys are playing you guys
have completely different experiences
and you've been you become the author of
your own story and so it's not just
about sort of how big the world is but
it's also how responsive it is one of
the things that's cool for us is that
we're building this resistance we have
this resistance meter and as you begin
to build your lore and as you begin to
as people start to know you
maybe somebody maybe you go in and you
take over falls in and you basically
push back the cult somebody's gonna say
that afterwards hoo you're the one you
took over listen you need to go get you
need to meet this person or somebody's
gonna say you know what you could use I
think eg is a dog ok or a different
animal and yeah you're integral in
building and growing this resistance and
hope county that's passing so I assume
aside from those bits there is a main
narrative thread in there to pull you
through yeah how do you marry wanting to
tell that main narrative thread story
with with such a big world with so many
things to do I mean I know in my
experience when I played you know huge
open world RPGs I absolutely love them
but I do tend to lose the plot yeah
literally yes um it's a good question I
think it's it's it's not an easy thing
to do
I think what's important for us to do
and the way we tackled it was is that we
made it so that there were residents of
the world and there were residents of
these individual communities and what
you're doing is let's say that you go
into the world and you go into let's say
you head down south into John's region
and you're gonna find the community of
Falls and you're gonna meet Mary you're
going to meet pastor Jerome and they're
going to kind of blossom out in terms of
telling you the different stories that
are potentials for you to be able right
yeah but at the same time John is going
to be aware of you and what we do is we
make sure that once you've done a
certain amount and push the cult to a
certain degree he then descends down and
basically you have that face time so
that you guys have the opportunity to
meet him face to face because if you
don't meet the villain if you don't sort
of feel them right if they don't step
into your presence it doesn't feel real
so we make sure that you're gonna push
he's gonna push back you go into faiths
region you're gonna push she's gonna
push back you have this experience of
them sort of them being front and center
in front of you and then when you have
that experience and where it'll tell
that story you're reminded of them as
they keep showing up yeah
not sure if you would agree on this
point that a far cry at this point
certainly appears to have its own kind
of formula I wonder how much five is
going to continue with that and how much
it's stepping away from that you know I
think that when we talk about the main
thing for us that we want to be able to
do is is be surprising and meat fresh
right so we had an opportunity to make a
game that would be I think that would be
very very similar to something we've
done before and you can tell the job by
choosing to go to Montana it was
unexpected
just by choosing a story where you go in
any direction meet any character the
question that I keep getting asked is
you know okay so you're gonna climb
towers and you're gonna do ya know
towers
legally different already different yeah
yeah yeah well that's great I was
wondering I'm not sure if you can talk
about this yet uh with the coop how is
that gonna work with who your characters
are well I think that what we did from
that standpoint as well to make sure
that you were able to if you're playing
the single-player campaign and that
you're you you built your character you
can invite somebody to play into your
game but basically it's not going to
affect who you are in your storyline
yeah it's basically like another guns
for hire but it's go up yeah so I mean
you said there's a lot of freedom
with how you engage with the world does
that still apply to combat as well you
can get into it everywhere you want you
well I know my dad absolutely loves your
games and he will only snipe your dad -
my god if someone sees him here he's
like done he's like no no that's not how
I get into it
yeah um is it still like completely free
you can just like yeah pick up whatever
weapons engages it in that way I think
that one of the things that we want to
do is we know we're building this
anecdote Factory and the thing that we
did with guns for hire and thanks for
hours we wanted you to be able to bring
them with you
right so now you can actually begin to
build your squad and take them out and
bring them with you but in terms of how
you explore the game how you attack
moments the moment it's completely free
do what you want to do play the way you
want to play it yeah can you talk a
little bit about what's unique to the
Montana setting as far as combat goes
because in one of the trailers we've
seen there was a pitchfork kill that I
thought was very interesting is there
anything else or tractor kills it was
really cool yeah it was really cool
about going to Montana is that it really
felt like there have been a history of
self-reliance and so something as simple
as a tractor becomes a weapon something
as simple as a plane like Nick all of a
sudden you got death from above and
bombs and whatnot hey I think that what
we just liked was the idea that when you
looked around the landscape you saw
opportunities right you get into a big
rig you want to get it you know for me
what I like to do is I like to get into
a classic muscle car yeah just drive
down the road cool tunes playing and
then start off-roading right so I think
we just started to pepper the world with
all these different opportunities and
let you use them the way you want to use
them but there are some things that are
uniquely American getting in that muscle
car getting in that plane hearing the
right piece of music as you're doing it
right it fuels fuels right going into
the bar and sitting there and talking to
Mary Mae or meeting KC we're going to
meet pastor Jerome or getting into the
big rig and just basically taking the
Blackwood or sorry the Widowmaker all
the way down the road and being able to
do it's super cool to be able to see
that and do that yeah I actually wanted
to ask you if the music I'm so glad you
brought that up because I got into the
big rig when I was playing uh and Black
Keys was on and you'd only switch the
radio and I just I want to know a little
bit more about like like how much goes
into selecting what music you want to be
in there on the radio honestly because
we've been making this game for like two
and a half years we we really you know
you got a couple of summers where you're
driving down the road and that and you
just you're listening to the music and
thinking about the type of music that we
want to put in the game it's as simple
as we're actually in Montana and we're
in this bar and there was this there was
this jukebox and we're going up to it
and just looking at all the music all
the classics cool stuff yeah and we
thought okay this is what makes the
world feel real that you're driving
along and the right piece of music comes
on or you're flying and it feels right
like the big rig all these different
things or even going just going house to
house that was the other thing that was
really interesting for us is that for
the first time we're in this sort of
semi urban environment yeah going into
houses and you're seeing how people live
in your and you're kind of going into
these villages in these towns and you're
getting a sense of the lifestyle it's
got to feel real right ruled has to feel
believable so we did a ton of research
yeah I mean like I got in that big rig
and it just I don't know about you but
whenever I go on a road trip I have like
specific Road yeah yeah and like it's
music I don't even listen to you I'm
just kind of listening to music on my
own amazed wow it's like it's
specifically for road trips I do a lot
of like classic rock but that's what
reminded me have I gotten a bigger and I
was like oh wow okay I'm like driving
down the highway like it can change your
total experience wrong song comes on for
you being in that moment where you just
want to be alive down the road you know
what it feels wrong we make sure we did
a lot of time it took a lot of time to
make sure the right piece of music came
up yeah you don't want like a gta5 style
radio like jay-z wanting you want we
want you to be able to make it so that
it just feels right right yeah well the
tower's pod is a really interesting bit
is there anything else you can tell us
about like something far cry fans might
not expect that is changing or happening
in five trying to think um in terms of
like one thing I think we really looked
as we looked at the sort of the breath
of the game when you think of what we're
doing about the location you think about
what we're doing a story in the
characters I think we just wanted it to
feel real so I think that people if you
played a four crowd game before and
we're seeing that on the floor people
are playing and they're going awed feels
familiar but it feels different like
okay that's good that's good and they're
enjoying it but even people who've never
played a far cry before they can come in
and they can join the game and get a
sense that wow this is like this feels
like a real trip to Montana this feels
really interesting the cult is unique
the way that you sort of explore the
world and all the characters that you
bring with you and then just the fact
that you can have your own pet that I
mean that the game is is generous and we
want to make sure that people get a
chance
play it here at e3 right yeah and you're
able to design your own protagonist this
time around is that right yep what was
the motivation behind that as opposed to
making asset protection just honestly
just making it so that it was as as thin
as possible from the standpoint of we
want it to be you we want you to be well
when I play a game I want it to be me
going in there and I don't want to hear
that voice that doesn't make sense yeah
yeah just wanted to be me and I want to
feel like him in the space yeah we
thought it was a great opportunity what
you probably can't speak to it yeah but
do you have any idea what the breadth of
that customization is like yeah we can't
talk about that yeah I want to but that
person right there will stop me
you get in trouble um you gotta let
quite a while to the game comes out
you're in February next year so we're
about this development out right now I
think we just did the stuff that people
are playing is just pre-alpha we're
right around alpha and so what what's
great is is that you know we've been
looking at this for a while and we're
like you know our people are gonna like
it housing and the truth is is that
they're going nuts on the floor with
anyway it's really we're loving it the
have a great time yeah are you taking is
there any feedback you're taking that
you reckon you'll take back to the
developer yeah Russ right I mean
watching people like I think we all knew
that boomer was gonna be a star we gonna
be a superstar but it's cool and and
just seeing what people like seeing how
they're playing the fact that you know
people that are really enjoying flying
and I think that's something else that
we do a lot of is when we watch people
play fishing okay something as simple as
fishing like we're yes we're making a
shooter and yes we're building this big
world yeah we're noticing is is that
people are waiting in line and they're
waiting a long time to play yeah they
only have 10 to 15 minutes and they
spend the entire time fishing and gamers
love using this amazing there's a
surprising amount of fishing in games uh
yeah so you really have been noticing
that I meant to ask about the reception
on the show floor it sounds like it's
been really good a lot of people are
just fishing yeah it's really Clendon
they're not bad people each other I
kinda love that we we were in Montana
and we went fishing with this guy and it
was just the pearls of wisdom that came
out of this guy were fantastic and so we
have to build a world where if you
decide that you want to drive down the
highway and you want to listen to tunes
you can do that if you want to get in a
plane and fly around if you want to have
dogfights if you want to strafe if you
want to take boomer out if you want to
take gray so you can do that at the same
time if you just want to sit down and
fish fish
well that sounds absolutely excellent
we were really excited to play the game
I can't wait to see more I know we've
got a bit of a wait but it sounds like
it's going to be worth it
thanks so much for talking again and
yeah we'll be wrapping up for now but
stay with us for more